and then lastly trump says he's writing  a book called the crime of the century  about how i guess the election was  stolen from him kind of getting sad at  this point anything about it they go  after other people  they don't want to go after criminals  that kill people on the streets they go  after other they go f they like going  after republicans that's what they  really like this is the greatest this is  the crime of the century i'm actually  writing a book about called the crime of  the century i don't think you'll enjoy  it you'll be very depressed when you're  well i i just don't believe trump's  writing anything trump doesn't read and  trump doesn't write so none of it is  making sense to me so a completely  depraved event trump doesn't know up  from down day from night left is right  unclear what's going on but he continues  to be completely unempathetic in every  way to everything going on in the world